it's just impossible it's impossible I
keep using social media
I can't lumen text this is this ISM this
is too difficult today we are here to
not use products that women have made
for an entire day I think it's gonna be
like oh yeah that's fine it's just a day
but I feel like I'm going to be wrong
and it today is gonna be horrible I
think there's gonna be a lot of things
that we don't expect on this list that
we're not gonna be able to use some
things that I knew already that were
invented by women we are going to pick
from this bowl each one's gonna be an
invention and we're gonna guess if it
was a man or a woman who made it
improved can opener I don't even know
there was an unimproved the same dude
I'm gonna say a dude computer software
woman woman touch-tone phone caller ID
call waiting I'm gonna say a lady I'm
gonna greet windshield-wiper I would say
dude I'm gonna say a woman because I'm
pretty sure they're driving it's raining
she's like honey you can't see you need
like something to clear the windshield
wiper he's like I got this okay Cheryl I
got it and so she was like when we think
of something so we he doesn't kill me
gas heating furnace I'm gonna say a
guide all this great square bottom paper
bag I'm gonna say guy on this really
really that's wild
that's so cool now that we know all
these things were invented by women
we're gonna try to do the day without
that was gonna be bad bad yeah
everything that was invented by women is
essentially advanced the current day and
age of how we live cuz I feel like I'm a
damn caveman it was harder than I
thought
the phones probably gonna be the hardest
challenge debates during the week so I'm
off to drink beer I don't
really need any males just kind of
seeing the list I was like okay I think
I could do this just just a day no well
I'm a bit of a pretty frustrated hardest
challenge was using my not using
anything on my cell phone so we just got
off the restroom and of course I right
away started using social media on my
phone we're not allowed to use our cell
phones at all and the fact that I went
straight to the restroom and went
straight to all my apps and Instagram
it's this is gonna be harder than I
thought I kind of enjoyed you know the
kind of disconnecting in a way kind of
just like liberating a little bit it's
been harder and harder to do certain
things like technology-wise we can't use
the Wi-Fi we can't use the GPS so I
don't know how I'm supposed to do work
you know some emails out no the biggest
challenge for me it was having really
bored poops like I would go poop and I
can't go on any apps on my phone so I'm
just sitting there staring at a wall so
it's round 2 of the most boring poop
ever I was kicked out of my desk because
it would happen to be cold they wanted
to put on the heater which I cannot use
so I'm officially kicked out and I have
to sit somewhere else so now I have to
be cold and Wi-Fi lists really a step
back in time why name to go you know
grocery shopping and when I was checking
out the checkout person asked me if I
wanted a brown you know paper bag or a
plastic bags at home and we're now
allowed to use square bottom paper bags
so instead I have my food chilling with
me and caught myself she's like would
you like a paper bag I was like no I do
not want a paper bag I couldn't go on
Netflix cuz I mean that was kind of a
thinking stream on my computer have
nothing to watch because I can't use
Wi-Fi which means I can't use any
entertainment whatsoever or internet or
Netflix or Hulu or anything else
overall it was way more seemingly
difficult than I thought and it just
made me really appreciate these these
women there's a lot of great everyday
inventions that are made our lives
easier that had been made by women
and you know sometimes just gonna sit
back and appreciate those things
[Music]